[Applause]
good afternoon president Ouattara it is
a pleasure to welcome you at Columbia
and I would like to thank you for our
community for accepting to come and have
a conversation with us this afternoon
it's also a pleasure to welcome you all
to vist columbia world leaders forum
event as i already mentioned we are
joined today by his Excellency dr.
Allison Ouattara president of the
Republic of côte d'ivoire Madame
Dominic Claudine water our first lady of
Cote d'Ivoire and the members of the
Vorian delegation I would like to
acknowledge the co-sponsor of this event
along the world leaders forum be calm be
a University Institute of African
Studies please before introducing his
Excellency president Ouattara
I would like to introduce briefly the
world leaders forum and its purpose the
world leaders forum was founded in 2003
by our president Lee Bollinger to
support robust dialogue on the most
pressing issues facing our global
society for 10 years it has allowed our
student faculty and staff to engage
directly with the man and the woman
involved in addressing the major
challenges of the 21st century by
allowing the university community to
enter into a conversation with leaders
who are grappling with major challenges
on the international stage the world
leaders forums allows Columbia
to feel full one of the most important
duties has a global center of learning
we take as an article of faith that only
through a free exchange of idea will
solution be found to the biggest problem
facing society it is an opportunity that
will be difficult if not impossible to
duplicate in any other city or any other
University Columbia has always been
among the most international institution
in the most global of American cities we
were large and growing percentage of
faculty graduate and undergraduate drawn
from Florin nation we have spent the
last four years creating a network of
global centers in eight cities Paris
stumble Amman Nairobi Mumbai virgin
Santiago and Rio de Janeiro our mission
demands a global perspective and
discussion like the one we are about to
have today's our cornerstone of this
poor sweet so please join me to welcome
again president water before I introduce
dr. Allison ouattara is the fifth
president of the Republic of côte
d'ivoire he was elected for the first
time in 2010 an economist by training he
also bachelor degrees in Business
Administration from Drexel Institute of
Technology in Philadelphia a master's
degree and a PhD in economics from the
University of Pennsylvania in
Philadelphia also in 1968 he joined the
International Monetary Fund where he
held position of increasing
responsibilities and later joined the
Central Bank of West African state bc AO
where at age 40 he became the deputy
governor and later the governor of a
bank in April 1990 why Korver was hit by
an unprecedented crisis dr. Alison
Ouattara was appointed by late president
philosopher bunny chairman of the inter
Ministerial Committee for coordination
of a stabilization program and economic
recovery a few months later he was
appointed as for devar first prime
minister and head of government until
December 1993 he then returned to the
IMF where he served as deputy managing
director the highest position held by an
African in this institution to date
following an extremely successful
international career dr. Ouattara
returned home in 1990 to take over the
presidency of one of cote d'ivoire major
political party but a sample Madeira
public are there in 19 in 2010 dr.
ouattara won
the election with 54 point 10 person of
Ward president Ouattara is considered
has buffet the father of a new emerging
cote d'ivoire
he introduced many Konami reforms that
transform côte d'ivoire and improved
Vallely who would be livelihood of
millions of Ivorian and the president
water a leadership code Ivar became the
third fastest growing economy in Africa
based on such an economic growth and
social social progress was experienced
during his first presidential term
president Ouattara was reelected for a
second term in October 2015 on the first
round of the election with 83 points 66
person of vote to be sufficient
biography I have just read I would like
to add two important elements to
highlight from a historical perspective
I am historian the contribution of
president Ouattara
to the recent political and economic
history of Africa first his persistence
in remaining in the public sphere which
has been criticized has proven that
Africans are not always caught in the
traps of political tribalism disparate
illegal maneuvers and the violence aimed
at excluding him under the accusation he
was not an Ivorian he won the
presidential election
ten years of propaganda against court
the stranger was decisively denied out
of a polls
second the success story of khaliv
khaliv our economy has been attributed
to his policies and reform though we are
not necessarily obligated to share his
liberal and globalization
globalizing conception of the governance
of economy we must recognize that he has
succeeded in restoring the economy of
Cote d'Ivoire successively has the
chairman of the committee for
coordination of stabilization program
has a prime minister and head of the
government in the early 90s and also has
a president of the Republic of côte
d'ivoire since 2010 what I would like to
ask the president is could he assured us
that it is possible to reenact the
miracle of RA in a global context when
the discussion about the future of the
CFA zone is raging but also to reconcile
Ivorian after the verity crisis his
excellency i would like again to thank
you for accepting our invitation to
discuss with us your expertise and
experience in the international stage
and grasp of a constraint of opportunity
of the African continent position you as
one of a best interlocutor in a
conversation on Global African
and Ivorian issue I am sure that you
will lend yourself with good grace
sometime has questions of our community
excellency the floor is yours
[Applause]
Thank You professor Jaffa members of
faculty vulnerable guests gerrae
students ladies and gentlemen my
delegation I think has come from the
72nd meeting of the General Assembly so
there are many of them here I can't
introduce all of them it will take a
good half an hour but we have a first
lady Dominique the secretary-general of
the presidency Minister of integration
minister of health minister of petroleum
Minister of Planning Minister of
solidarity the ambassador Chiefs of
Staff for the presidency special advisor
director of communication shall I
continue
no I should not but it's a great honour
and a real pleasure to be back at the
university environment as Prasad you
said I myself studied in the states a
few decades ago and at the University of
Pennsylvania and I was telling professor
Juve how much I enjoy being in this
particular environment and I'd like to
to thank the students for being here and
I understand we have three Ivorians
maybe they're not all here but at length
knowledge then person oka was bachelor a
Bachelor of Arts in financial economics
I don't know if easier easier when nice
to see you
and we have fo fanna briefs who is a PhD
in global history I don't think he's
here apparently is travelling between
Columbia Yale Harvard shows how every
ins our brilliant professor so I'm very
happy to acknowledge him Anita kata who
is an MBA in Africa's 2017 so I was told
that I could give you a brief a brief
presentation on challenges for
successful democratic transition and
leeching Africa's potential and to give
you the case of Cote d'Ivoire and
obviously could take a good half an hour
speaking about this but I'd like to be
brief and to tell you that this is quite
a challenge for Africans and an Africa
because our population today is 1.2
billion it's growing very fast and in
about 33 years by 2050 Africa will
account for one fourth or the world
population and it will have the youngest
population in the continent in the world
so this is clearly a major challenge for
governments but for the people of
African for the world I would say and
also it's a good opportunity because
obviously with a young population it
means having a strong manpower and also
a chances of accelerating technology and
innovation
and Africa of course 20 years ago was
seen as the hopeless continent that
economists today obviously this has
changed it was about 10 years ago
Africa's rising and now aspiring Africa
because the progress has been quite
impressive
and obviously this is due to a lot of
things that you know I will not insist
on them because of the abundant natural
resources of the continent and that we
have achieved also the strongest growth
rate in the world over the past the past
ten years or so the past three years
have been very difficult but clearly
we've been much above the growth rates
of the OECD countries and this is a
challenge I was saying because at this
pace in terms of population growth by
2050 Nigeria will be the third most
populated country ahead of after China
and India and ahead of the United States
in terms of population and I think if my
recollection is right Ethiopia and Congo
Kinshasa will be among the ten most
populated countries in in the world so
this shows how much potential there is
in terms of demography and obviously
this would require that the governments
work hard well develop policies which
can create jobs and also absorb the
young population and to avoid some of
the problems that we've been talking
about today actually at the UN a
question about my
raishin of a younger through the Sahara
dying in the Mediterranean
because they're not allowed to reach to
reach Europe and obviously this
challenge we can try to do to do have
Senate it's not easy but I think it's
our responsibility and if we don't have
the right policies I think clearly it
will be a problem not only for Africa
but for the world at large as I said
getting the question of migration as an
example and today we had lunch with
President Trump we were not many just
nine head of states and we'd have some
of the issues we discussed with him to
get a bit more precision on his vision
for Africa and the policies of the
United States in the years to come now I
think to make sure that we continue to
make progress we need to ensure
political stability peace and security
and Cote d'Ivoire is a clear example of
this we had nearly four decades of peace
and tranquility from independence in
1962 nearly 2000 although a few years
before that we have some problems but
the worst years were between 2000 and
2010 when the country really went
through madness I would say but clearly
we need to strengthen the democratic
institutions and this has been doing
this is being done not only in Cote
d'Ivoire but Ghana is a clear example
Senegal and also Nigeria
and we need to also make sure that with
the leaders we make enough investment in
the major sectors or social sectors
health and good education especially
education of girls and we need to
develop and implement well-designed
national policies which we're doing in
Cote d'Ivoire and later on I'll give you
a few example as to our performance on
the economic and social field and many
of the African countries are among the
best performers in the world
the World Bank doing business reports
and I think this is quite quite a
welcome development for for our
continents one thing we all agree to
there and with the head of states where
whom we met is that we need to
accelerate the investment in
infrastructure and also the domestic
mobilization of resources domestic
resources because we need to finance
large-scale regional projects in not
only transport roads but in power in
energy and this is something which is a
challenge for many African countries and
basically one thing which is not working
very well in the continent is economic
integration and we need to deepen
original integration and I'm very proud
to say that this is a reality in West
Africa with ECOWAS the Economic
Community of West African states with
the 15 countries accounting for more
than 300 million people and also
the regional monetary and economic union
the West Africa of 100 million people
where clearly there is good coordination
of economic policies and three movements
of goods and people among the countries
and clearly Cote d'Ivoire is a champion
of this because in traffic and trade the
trade we have with other African
countries account for one-third of our
total trade well for Africa the average
is between ten and twelve percent so
accelerating integration is something
which is essential if you want to make
more progress to absorb this larger
demographic growth now in let me say a
few words about Cote d'Ivoire I think
this as I had noted the president you
have a professor you've said this is a
conversation so I don't want to read you
a speech but I'd like to give you a few
said she was about Cote d'Ivoire and
when I receive your question Cote
d'Ivoire has a central place in West
Africa we have the largest country is
Nigeria with 175 million people out of
300 million more 320 million then you
have the other bloc of countries
essentially the former french-speaking
countries which use the CFA franc you
mentioned accounting for about 100
million and all that group Cote d'Ivoire
clearly is an important partner because
it accounts for more than
35 percent of GDP more than 40 percent
of exports and so forth and the fact
that during the ten years of crisis
there was no investment in fact the
racial investment to GDP dropped to 210
percent 9 percent and growth was close
to zero while the population growth had
been more than 2 percent per year so
that means during those 10 years the
rate of poverty increased substantially
from what it was during the period 92-93
when I was Prime Minister and when we
were elected after four and a half
months in the Gulf oten surrounded by
the troops of my previous president we
developed team most of them are here
actually people develop a policy in fact
we develop what we call the presidential
of program of the urgency program
presidential difference so when we got
out of the Gulf hotel we were able to
start the implementation of this program
so actually being held hostages for four
and a half months it was not pleasant
but it was useful for the country since
we used to work together with my team at
any time some time I would call them at
midnight tell them why I have an idea
let's come and work on it so it Romania
as if I had been back at with Mercer
Pennsylvania so I enjoyed very much this
period despite the stress we went
through and our priorities were clear
and I think the achievements also we you
mentioned professor that we have held
democratic elections and we have set up
also through a referendum a new
constitution last year which now
provides like the United States
tickets president and vice president
this is the idea of strengthening the
regions of the country because clearly
the will of getting or keeping power is
so strong in Africa I think it's always
good to have some power sharing so that
it will not destabilize the country so
this is something which I personally
felt was important for my country and
this is what is in place in Ghana in
South Africa in Nigeria it's not
something usual in the trunk of one
country's so I must say we got a lot of
criticism but I'm sure with time people
see that we'll see that this is a major
contribution to the future stability of
my country in terms of achievements in
the economic policies we have over five
years 12 2012 to 2016 an average annual
growth rate of 9% which has been
sometime 10 percent some 10 8 % but on
the average 9 percent which is among the
10 highest growing countries in the
world and this allowed us in the
five-year period to increase our GDP by
50 percent and then reduce the degree
the level of poverty all were not
sufficient sufficiently and we were we
were able to do this full of course good
macroeconomic policies in terms of
keeping the deficit law keeping the debt
at a reasonable level and also making
sure that we met with structural reforms
necessary for for the country and in
fact the World Bank considered that we
were among for two consecutive years
where among the world
the best country's most reforming
countries in the world according to the
World Bank doing business reports and
these good base good performance was
also due to various investment codes
which we improved the mining code the
petroleum codes the general investment
code and so forth and as a result the
ratio of investment to GDP which was
about 9 percent in 2011 was 20 percent
in 2016 so it more than doubled this of
course explains why the growth rate had
been so high and at the same time we put
a lot of emphasis on social expenditure
health and education which allowed the
rate of poverty leading the poverty to
drop substantially during this period
and of course we met good progress on
employment especially youth employment
and we're very proud of that and in
terms of social expenditure we now make
sure that 1/3 of a budget is devoted to
social expenditures in health and
education because obviously we have so
much emphasis to private investment but
the private sector is really the main
engine of growth so the public sector
the government can emphasize and
concentrate on financing social social
expenditure so these are some of the
elements I wanted to share with you and
to say also that in improving health and
education that's not enough we try to
improve access to electricity we for
example
put we were able to raise the
electricity energy production from 40
percent by 2016
so to 2000 megawatt and my objective is
to for us to be able to raise this to
4,000 megawatts by 2020 and Cody where
is a country where the rate of
electricity being cut per year is the
lowest in Africa about four years ago
South Africa and Kaveri we're ahead of
us I think it's now about what 16 hours
per year Adama
16 hours per year of lack of electricity
which mean about one hour per month for
the whole country where you have
electricity if you go to some country
that will not mean you'll see that if
you lack the lack of electricity is
about 20 hours today so this is clearly
a major development and so in terms of
water production we were able in five
years
thanks to paprika she was minister of
infrastructure sitting next to the first
lady in five years we doubled the
production of water potable water
compared to the 50 years prior to our
arrival this shows how much progress was
made so in many areas where you did not
have any water for the population so we
were able to improve this and we built a
lot of classrooms of health centers and
so forth and so on so I don't want to
stay longer and Boza
and was up and this performance
so just to say that basically as of
today the economy is in very very good
shape despite the drop in the world
price of cocoa probably you know that
Cote d'Ivoire accounts for 40% world
cocoa and so anytime you eat a piece of
chocolate there is a good chance that
40% of it comes from Cote d'Ivoire so
we'll the first what would you serve
cocoa and the price of cocoa dropped by
by 35 to 40 percent earlier this year
and this obviously needed some
adjustment and also we had strikes we
had problems so many security forces
which needed more expenditure but I told
people versus the result of ready growth
and more wealth because everyone wants
to get his share and as a result you
have to get into dialogue to accommodate
these situations and as of today the
situation is quite good the prospects
are good and we think that our growth
rate should continue to be very high
seven to eight percent over the next few
years until until 2020 so this is a
professor mendella faculty some of the
highlights of my presentation I wanted
to do gave you and I said that it's a
conversation I wanted to tell you how
much the demographic growth is high in
Africa it's a good thing it's a
challenge but Cote d'Ivoire
today has 24 million by 2050 will have
more than 50 million by 2100 will have
more than 100 Megan larger population
than that of France and as I said
clearly Nigeria by 2050 will be the
third largest populated country in the
world
and with a future congo kinshasa which
have today 100 million each we'll have
250 foreign 300 million people this
means that we the officials have to do
our best to have good policies to be
open to trade to world trade to make
sure that we implement the right
policies so that job creation is a
reality especially for the young people
so professor thank you very much these
are some of the elements our bucket
[Applause]
thank you very much
His Excellency for a clear very detailed
presentation which highlighted issues
which are both global had I was saying
African and Ivorian for the Q&A I would
like to set both rules to make sure that
everybody who wants to ask a question
will have a chance to ask it and will
give his Excellency the time to answer
your question so you have I think two
mics you know in the aisles the idea is
if you want to ask a question you can
line up behind one of the mics and I
will call on you and you will be able to
ask your question so but two mics are
there so but floor is open but the only
thing I would like to ask you to do when
you come to ask your question is to
state your name and what school you are
studying or affiliated from
hello your excellency thank you so much
for sharing your remarks with us and for
taking the time to be with us this
evening my name is Rachel McCauley I am
a alumna of Columbia University's School
of International and public affairs
studied economic and political
development now working for an African
agribusiness company based here in New
York you touched a little bit about Cote
voise cocoa production I'd like to hear
a little more about agriculture and some
of the things that African countries can
do to make themselves a global player in
production we know that Africa is home
to a lot of the world's arable land but
produces only a small fraction in terms
of global food so what are the things
that you think need to be put in place
in order for African countries to be
global producers thank you thank you hi
thank you very much for having me too
this is sumikko Sasaki and I am a
faculty member here in Colombia at supa
I teach East Asian security but also I'm
a director of NGO called
distance education for Africa and I'm
talking to the African people every week
so I have two questions one is about
corruption and one needs about the
tribal divide and sounds like that the
Cote d'Ivoire is overcoming very well
which is reflected in your economic
growth so I wonder how you cope is to a
very critical issues in Africa thank you
thank you well thank you very much I
think for the first question on
concerning cocoa yes we are the first
one producer of cocoa but I should also
mention that we were first one producer
of cashew nuts over the past two years
before India which was the first one
producer we're the first African
producer of banana first African
producer a pineapple and so forth and so
on so this shows that Cote d'Ivoire has
a very very comprehensive
Adric
on policy this was really implemented by
our first president and we need to be
thankful to him because when you see two
there for the past three years the
problem that the oil producing countries
are having having put emphasis on
agriculture and the diversification of
agriculture will is a blessing
thanks to that despite the drop in the
price of cocoa we're going to have a
growth rate of 7% this year which is
clearly something outstanding and we
believe that for all these products we
have a comprehensive plan which has as a
counterparts the development of consumer
products like rice for example we have a
self sufficiency rice production program
which by next year or the year after we
should be able to produce enough rice
for our domestic consumption and even be
able to export it to some of the
neighboring countries while three four
years ago we used to import about 1/3 of
the rice consumption and we also are
doing a lot to improve the production of
vegetables and tomatoes and so forth and
so on so we think clearly this is going
to be a focus of our policy to develop
agriculture not only for exports but for
our domestic consumption what you are
intend to remain the major agricultural
economy at the same time whether new
mining code the petroleum code we're
having with increasing very sharply the
production of gold for example we're now
at 30 tons 3-0 of tons of gold
production we had we were at less than
ten five years ago and
the trend on production is also rising
and we have other minerals which are
being exploited but we believe it's
important to make sure that agriculture
continues to be the main stream of our
policy now on the question of the
corruption and trade and trade I'll
divide this is a problem for Africa
I agree corruption for all all countries
because as people said to have
corruption you have to have some people
who also encourage corruption and we
have been very very tough on this issue
of corruption I agree that because of
the 10 years of bad governance in my
country from 2000 to 2010 it was very
difficult initially in the
administration but we took a lot of
measures including the declaration of
wealth we set up a high authority for
good governance and so forth but the
implementation of this next time but we
do hope that the private sector now
acknowledges that the problem of
corruption is less to death than it was
a few years back but of course it's not
it's not wiped out the way I would like
personally but we will continue on this
one request I'll try bail denied you are
right this has been the measure of
problem of Cote d'Ivoire you see the
country as has had liberal policies in
the economic field but openness also in
terms of the population intake and as a
result as of today
cada Juarez 24 million people but out of
the 6 million are from the neighboring
countries that means is 25%
of the population is from County I've
done are not every Coast nationals
and obviously at some stage if this is
exploited politically this creates a
problem and pressure do formation what
we went through during that period when
people try to use this politically but
now the nationality code has been
improved to make sure that all those who
were born in Cote d'Ivoire before
independence are considered your
librarian or in their parents were born
in Cote d'Ivoire before independence and
so forth and also we try to improve the
naturalization process to make sure that
we get people who can make a good
contribution to the economy and the
country to health every cost nationality
without much problem so see this is yeah
and also a new constitution for example
indicates that to be a presidential
candidate you have a part to be of our
young descent by one of your parents
while the previous Constitution used to
say that you had to prove that your
father your grandfather you're all the
great great great great great fathers
from Cote d'Ivoire while Cote d'Ivoire
existed on his since 1960 so it was
completely ridiculous but everyone
understood it was used to make sure that
competitors will not be able to get into
a race where democracies to let everyone
become a candidate so that the people
decide and not a group of people sit in
a room and decide who should be able to
contest so the new constitution gives
full openness to candidacy when people
want to run for office so these are some
of the elements I wanted to give on this
to thank you
his excellency I thank you for a very
good presentation
my name is Trevor agua I'm a Sambhav one
who was born and raised in Botswana I'm
a sophomore at Columbia College so I
actually have two questions
firstly you talked about how there are
problems in African countries in terms
of economic integration and I was
wondering if you could elaborate more
about some of the problems which African
countries face you don't have to really
go into detail about the names of
countries and also I wanted to know like
maybe like one of the best things which
you can say which people should know
about Cote d'Ivoire like the best yeah
so like yeah thank you what's the second
part I didn't get the the best thing
about audible yes thank you
Idris Osama so president my name is
idrees Fofana
and I'm a PhD student in the Department
of History with my friend accent in the
back we're one of the Ivorian students
here at Columbia and we apologize they
just found out this was happening seeing
the delegations vehicles outside so not
very well prepared but my question you
mentioned the that a lot of the basis
for every coasts current success
economically were founded under their
first president and during that history
but one must also recognize that a lot
of the problems of the country underwent
between 2000 2010 also have roots in his
deeper history so my question is what
lessons do you think we must draw for my
experience over the 40 50 years of
independence and what have you done to
make sure that those mistakes aren't
repeated in the future thank you Thank
You mr. president and thank you
professor doof is actually my professor
this semester I'm taking his class of
Africa before colonialism my name is
arson oka and I'm a former professional
soccer player I represented the country
of Ivory Coast's many times and Colombia
gave me a second chance to go back to
school so I am a senior at the school of
general studies
I'm studying financial economics I have
two questions
mr. president the first one is about
economics it is not a secret that the
Chinese economy is moving from the
manufacturing stage to the service stage
this means there is an opportunity for
African countries to attract all these
investments and create jobs for example
ET opere is already benefiting from
these opportunities
what are your plan or what are you what
are you planning to do for every course
in order to attract these investment and
create jobs the second question is not
really a question as you can see we are
many Ivorians going to school in the
United States it's a great country where
we are learning a lot a lot of skills
through Columbia University again some
experience in Investment Banking
I also gained some experience in
corporate finance working for different
grid corporation we love our country and
we want to help develop a country what
are you planning to help us go back and
help your country Thank You mr.
president and thank you professor Diouf
thank you well thank you for the
question concerning economic integration
well obviously one can spend a lot of
time about about
developing this but what is important to
know is to create the conditions I think
there are two areas where it works quite
well
one is the COAS and the other static
because clearly there is political win
and also the countries have goods to
trade with each other and I think that
is also a good environment where you
from Zimbabwe but globally a good
democratic environment in most of the
countries and I think all this helps in
terms of setting rules abiding by them
and so forth so it's not easy I would
say because sometimes when people see
that one of the country code bar for
example has been making a lot of
progress and want to export goods to
some other countries it requires that we
send our ministers to convince our
partners but this is in accordance with
our community rules and nationals from
other countries can come and work easily
in Cote d'Ivoire but I've lived there
myself in other countries in West Africa
is very difficult for a variance to work
in the other countries so you have to
have well to get the environment both in
terms of the rules the regulations
I think coordinated and to have to make
them fair in terms of access to everyone
so but it's not an easy and easy thing
to do in West Africa
one of the
advantages we have yourself among the 15
countries of the 15 countries eight
already in an economic and monetary
union so they are the same manner they
have the same legal framework and so
forth so same language and so this has
facilitated things and then you have
Nigeria which is a country by itself a
continent I would say by itself and so
far so this is you and you have the same
thing in the sad a group with South
Africa being an engine so if you have
engines of reality integration it can
work and Cote d'Ivoire has been an
engine for integration by absorbing the
population of other countries now you
said what's the best thing about Cote
d'Ivoire I was as hospitality really
Ivorians are known to be hospitable
people so this is you come to Cote
d'Ivoire and spend a few days and you'll
see that everyone people are nice and
good people thank you
and now it is said that I talked about
what our first president did for us on
in the economic field
and what is clearly saying that some of
the political problems that we inherited
was of his doing and I agree I agree
fully because we for 40 kids we had a
one-party system and so forth and I
think the lesson I would draw from that
is that it's important to have democracy
and fair elections and make sure that
people have an equal access to the
wealth of the country to the problems of
the country the method equal access to
making the contribution to the country
so clearly way and I think this is the
idea of the new constitution but we have
set up to make sure that it forces in a
way political integration and at the
same time it gives an opportunity for
everyone to compete and if a competition
is fair people will decide and I think
it's important that someone does not
take one person for as a ruler of the
country and as Anoka mentioned well that
the Chinese economy and the performance
of the Chinese investment in Africa this
is something we we recognize and we're
working very well with the Chinese in
terms of coming and setting up
manufacturing industries in Cote
d'Ivoire it's important for example we
produce cocoa but we process only 1/3 of
our cocoa production two fares are sent
outside without any processing
so I've talked to a Chinese and I said
well why don't you come and sit
manufacturing industries to transform
the cocoa into cocoa butter and cocoa
paste so that and then send them to
China if you want to produce chocolate
for the Chinese and so forth and so on
and we went we have proposed that they
do this and working with the Vietnamese
for example to do this in the area of
cashew nuts because we produce marble
700,000 tonnes of cashew nuts
more than India with the first producer
but we process only 8% of the Eternals
so we're encouraging them to step and is
reason code evolved to process the
cashew nuts and so forth so I think
clearly there is a good possibility for
having the Chinese set of industries in
our countries now you every and in the
u.s. you know every time I travel to a
country we have a menu servant
aggression with me I don't know where
Elesha I used to meet with the audience
in the official visits this is an office
is not an official visit but everywhere
we go we meet with your audience and
tell them well you're studying here
you're working in here meaning in France
in Spain in Portugal in Turkey when you
finish come back to cultivar because
it's a growing economy it's a country
which has a lot of potential and you
have industries from all those countries
setting up offices in Cote d'Ivoire and
if L speak Chinese we're in China
obviously when they go back to Co the
world they'll find a job easily in a
Chinese in a Chinese company so I know
that you are a former soccer player I
have another friend who's a former
soccer player of Liberia who is running
for president
see for every office in October so good
luck to you from the future so I'm very
sorry we don't have enough time the only
thing I can do is take one man and one
woman okay I will take beside a woman
and beside the man for Burris I'm really
sure we are running out of time hi your
excellency um thank you for your speech
um both my parents are from Korea and
they came here and I was the first I'm
the second child they had here my dad
always talked something about going to
Ivory Coast and being ambassador but
Lucy my question is to piggy um Jesus
talked about how a lot of librarians
come here to pursue their education I
was just wondering if you have any plans
to improving the education including
laws so that their variance can stay
there and help their country out let's
that's it
yes I think the second second thank you
hello your excellency thank you for
taking the time to talk to us today my
name is Madhu charm I'm originally from
the Gambia West Africa and I'm studying
sustainability management at the
Institute and the School of Professional
Studies
you mentioned Cody Juarez energy
capacity and the fact that the goal is
to double it by 2020 your country signed
the sustainable development goals in
2015 and the promise was to develop your
country sustainably are you planning to
uphold that promise and develop the
energy sector or sustainably
specifically the goal is goals 7 which
is sustainable energy for all thank you
well thank you very much on the question
of students coming here to study this is
Luis I think Minister Tonka and myself
we're among the first students ivory
honest of students who come to to the
u.s. to study in the early 60s and since
then of course many many more have come
and I think and also many have returned
to cut away and you are right to say
what are we doing to improve the
education and a higher education system
in Cote d'Ivoire so but students can
study in Cote d'Ivoire as well but this
is what we're doing you see when I
remember when I was Prime Minister from
90 to 93 we only had one university but
in 3 years I was able to set up a second
University and now when we came back in
2011 at the presidency we have been able
this base universities were not
functioning at all as you know the
militia were from the University and
they it was used for other things than
studying
and drug trafficking really a lot of
problems so we rehabilitated the
universities in addition and since when
we have set up three more universities
and obviously this program will continue
now Kjetil is a hope by 2020 to have all
the regional the districts will have a
university where ten districts in Cote
d'Ivoire I think clearly if Coco shock
is not can be contained is to try to
have eight to ten universities in Cote
d'Ivoire by 2020 or today we have five
so we have three to three more to do
before them
so we also probably know that whatever
has one of the best higher education
schools in Yamoussoukro the Institute
Polytechnic and we like and for example
this year I understand that to go to a
French Polytechnic schools I think out
of seven Africans who were recruited CCA
can correct me I think five of them were
from Cote d'Ivoire so there shows that
the quality of education is quite as
quite improved in Cote d'Ivoire and of
course many students are coming here and
I think this exchange is good not me I
don't think we should just develop
universities in Cote d'Ivoire and close
down and Ivorians and not let them have
a chance to to open themselves up to go
to other countries to Senegal to France
to the US that's where now on the Gambia
the question of the SVG's clearly we we
are permitted to that and we are doing
quite well because rate they access the
drug at 80% in Cote d'Ivoire and we're
one of the countries we are having very
good performance so we're confident that
we reach reach reach goals professor you
had mentioned you address the you have
said that you wanted me to talk about
this
Frank I think another point you said is
well let me talk about the CFA franc you
know you had a lot of discussion about
the common currency but I think all of
you have studied the common currency
theory and we believe that over the past
five decades or more should say six
decades the fact that we had a common
currency in West Africa and in central
Africa it's been a good thing
globally obviously this it all depends
on the type of policies that the
individual countries implement central
bank myself director of research deputy
governor as a professor you've said and
then governor and we try to improve not
only the management of the bank and also
the monetary policy at the bank and I
remember when I was director of research
we were implementing monetary forecasts
to try to calculate the amount of money
supply we should put out before the Bank
of France you see so people have the
reverse idea that we're getting
everything from France but the central
bank has been really a very autonomous
institution and I will also say that if
we did not have this common currency
probably in the 1990s Cote d'Ivoire
would have had an economic catastrophe
the Solidarity and the fact that it's a
common management of the currency
gives the pressure on the authorities
the national authorities to implement
good financial and budget policies in
fact professor burgers had lunch with
President McCrone in France and I was
telling me look if we if we had a
national central bank in Cote d'Ivoire
we'll just drop in the price of cocoa as
a politician my first sentence would
have been to devalue and so that I
continued to get the farmers the same
price gave them money elusion and not
take the difficult measure of reducing
the domestic price of cocoa but that's
what we did we reduce the domestic price
of cocoa and this about inflation to be
contained and also give the compensation
to other sectors so globally we need to
continue our reflection on the CFA franc
but I am NOT those who think that this
is all bad and I think we should try to
have a larger monetary area and we hope
but to include all the ECOWAS countries
because the larger area is after all
people forget the United States you have
the dollar circulates a dollar of New
York circulates in Colorado or in
Florida but it's the same thing we
should do and in Europe I will tell the
people who say well why don't you have
your own currency France the French
franc today we have the euro and the
euro circulates in Germany it circulates
in France in Italy in Spain that does
not make it a bad currency the main
thing is domestic national policies have
to be
convergent have to be sustainable and
have to be in conformity with the
domestic needs to finish and rest I
would say that it was when I was
governor when I indicated to the head of
states that we had a monetary policy at
that time in the late 80s Union had an
economic integration but they did not
they were having problem setting up a
monetary union so I told the president
you say well look since we already have
the most difficult part having a
monetary union let's have an economic
union so that's how we came to set up
the economic and monetary union of West
Africa Thank You professor thank you
he's excellent
before giving you two minutes for your
final conclusions I would like to thank
my colleagues our student who has been
present have asked excellent questions
which is a testimony of the education
Colombia is giving them I would also
like to thank president Ouattara for his
thoughtful presentation for both
discussing the present and the future of
the continent highlighting the
trajectories of West Africa but also of
of Ivory Coast which has really enabled
a frank conversation and in particular I
would like to thank him for discussing
at the end the Frank safe and what I
will really like to ask him this is a
question my colleagues but also many
African scholars are interested in is
ivory coast organizing a real discussion
about the Ivorian
experience since the crisis because I
think that lesson can be learned from
that experience and the reflection on
that experience is absolutely crucial
for the progress of not only democratic
institution in Africa but the progress
of the democratic conversation for that
I would like to to thank him because
it's also important for a politician
to know the facts and I think that
president Ouattara has shown us that he
knows the facts thank you very much
again well thank you professor I'd like
to thank you for having given me this
opportunity to make this address to the
world leaders forum and to thank the
students and all those who are here and
who had taken the time to come and
listen to me and was really quite a
straight straight forward in my
presentation and talking through fully
about developments in Cote d'Ivoire with
not good progress it's true with with
made mistakes also and I think clearly
there is a challenge challenge for for
all of us but particularly for the young
people who are here you are the next
leaders the of Cote d'Ivoire of Africa
and of your countries and I believe it's
important for you to at some stage to go
back to Africa to your countries to help
because the experience in universities
like Colombia is your Pennsylvania
elsewhere Yale Harvard are quite quite
enormous for the future of our continent
and I'm very grateful for the time you
have spent to listen to what I had to
say goodnight to all of us
[Applause]